but it's almost like when he decides
that that the chaos has overcome the
situation
he remains completely calm and everybody
else just loses their minds and they
can't like like even though he's not
lamar jackson yeah he becomes as
slippery and elusive as lamar jackson in
that moment it's infectious through the
team like you know we've heard through
the years like you know hey the patriots
they know they got brady they always
believe the packers have rogers they
always believe
you know his looseness and just never
flinching ability it just i've never
heard
a coach like i said dean pease an nfl
legend defensive coordinator
telling my father leading up to the afc
championship game we're not going to
really blitz you can't rattle patrick
mahomes we've seen two years of games
and it just doesn't happen and it's just
amazing the poise he's had from the
second he's got an nfl and really mike
the other thing i add to it is like has
he ever really had a bad game in the nfl
no right now like his bad games are like
okay 180. three touchdowns or 182
touchdowns but still a few highlight
plays that's where i just i'm amazed by
the man i really am as i continue to go
back and forth with regret possibly from
my super bowl pick watching those
highlights i know i feel a lot better i
hear i feel a lot better i was sitting
there watching that going oh man i don't
know it's is this 49ers pass rush gonna
be able to get this guy but and that's
the thing we showed
uh earlier in the week the tarkenton
play that we we call it from week three
of the 2018 season when the 49ers played
at arrowhead stadium and and they didn't
have nick bosa or d ford to chase
patrick mahomes and the question i keep
coming back to is would it have made a
difference right and and i i i compare
mahomes in that context to aaron rodgers
because when i went back and watched the
packers 49ers game from week 12 trying
to figure out is there a way the packers
can thread that needle and pull off the
victory right
when rogers was on the move
nick bosa and company could not get to
it yeah right so look i think the
packers failed to have our aaron rodgers
on the move as much as they should have
patrick holmes is always on the move
there was a play in the titans game
where he's got 10 seconds in the pocket
and he doesn't stand there he's
constantly moving and he's ready to go
and he's always looking when do i have
to go when do i have to go he will
always be on the move against the 49ers
and i don't think those guys are gonna
be able to track him no i mean i mean
listen
you know we we've exhausted the topic
but it is like i think the main topic of
the football game i you know i don't
think i've ever ever seen anybody and i
never thought i would say this really
because i thought aaron rodgers was the
master manipulator of a pocket in his
prime to be able to dance around and do
those things
mahomes doesn't dance around and like
hop around like rogers does he just like
smoothly moves here and fades away there
and and he like you said he just has
this great innate ability to like kind
of see the pass rush but also see
downfield you never feel like oh man he
missed somebody open downfield because
he was looking at the pass rush or he
didn't feel the guy coming off the edge
because he was looking down the field he
always seems to know what's around him
and
that's why he's the best in the sport
right that's why we never see him do
anything stupid because he knows the
limits of his abilities we talked about
this earlier in the week how he colors
within the lines the lines are very
broad yeah but he always stays within
those lines you don't see him do that
brett favre thing like what the hell was
right like that was quintuple coverage
why didn't he throw that ball and he
almost had to have known before he even
threw it it was gonna be picked off
mahomes knows what he can do it's the
difference between him and jameis
winston yeah winston all too often right
strays on the wrong side of that line
trying to do too much trying to will his
body to do something that it won't now
it helps that patrick holmes can do a
lot yeah but you would think with those
abilities he would from time to time try
to do more than he can he never does
that no he never does and you know
really i saw that in college when he was
coming out too and i had arguments with
like friends of mine in football too but
they were like oh he's a gunslinger he
plays too loose and i was like
it's 41 touchdowns and 10 interceptions
it's not that loose you're you're insane
that that's just like you're you're
you're judging him by the thing on his
helmet in the style and he plays the
game but you're not really looking at
the results that way and he's a
gunslinger who never misses a shot right
it's really rare i mean it's a
gunslinger who protects the football
yeah and that's where you just go that
doesn't make sense um
that release that that release because
we had dan marino earlier this week that
was his trademark the quick release but
it was from the more standard
quarterback position where you're
throwing the ball overhand by your ear
all the mechanics just right but with
mahomes when he's running full speed any
direction and can just just
just nanosecond gone right and it is a a
catchable ball with velocity and height
and everything it needs to be and its
place where it needs to be and it weaves
through guys it's just amazing it's
amazing and that's why
even though the 49ers have been special
this post season that run game may not
be solvable
i keep coming back to where patrick's
the home is unsolvable is what you come
back
patrick mahomes
where he is right now because he's
healthy
because we didn't see a lot of healthy
patron homes until january i think we
just have to acknowledge that that he's
the difference yeah hey listen i'm not
gonna i don't care if pat let me just
say this i don't give a damn if patrick
mahomes wins this super bowl or not he's
still amazing and i'm not gonna judge
him off of this one game you know this
is again we always get into this this is
more than you know a team sport i mean
this is more than a one-player sport
it's a team sport and his greatness is
undeniable so i'm not gonna go oh he he
lost the super bowl he can't win the big
game or he's not the best quarterback in
football i don't give a damn what
happens in this game when we go to the
2020 season he's the best player in
football no matter what it's not going
to change
and this is going to be a tough task and
a tough challenge for him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports